president biden is encouraging a new
effort to reopen schools for in-person
learning
now that coveted vaccination drives are
underway but teachers in some cities in
their labor unions they are pushing back
big time they say
it's still not safe enough for everyone
to return to school buildings
this national debate has left educators
and parents very frustrated
and divided too meg oliver has the story
in chicago it's a bitter school showdown
and sunday the teachers union for the
third largest district in the country
held a last-minute vote delaying
teachers returned to school
instead of heading back to class
yesterday teachers there will return
tomorrow
that has parents concerned their
children will not return to the
classroom
next week as planned how much should i
prepare her for this
if the you know carpet is going to get
pulled out from underneath her again
katie dempsey a high school math teacher
has been teaching in person since august
her husband is a first responder her son
is also back to in-person learning
leaving her six-year-old daughter joey a
chicago public school student
home to continue kindergarten online
she's experienced a great deal of
separation anxiety from me
when i do leave the house she'll try to
facetime me
multiple times asking when i'm coming
home she cries when i leave
across the country some 70 percent of
students are using some form of remote
learning
around 20 percent are learning
completely online
this month the american academy of
pediatrics released a statement saying
children absolutely need to return to
in-school learning for their healthy
development and well-being
adding new information tells us that
opening schools
does not significantly increase
community transmission of the virus
but many teachers across the country say
it's still
not safe to teach in person they're
seeing people
their friends their fellow teachers die
and it's it's to the point where people
are willing to stand up for themselves
on monday united teachers los angeles
said even getting vaccinated will not be
enough to return to
in-person learning in montclair new
jersey parents protested monday after
their return to an
optional hybrid model was canceled over
a lack of teachers
their union saying it wasn't safe
parents say their kids
are paying the price he can't get the
lesson
he doesn't see his friends it's just not
working
montclair is in the minority in new
jersey where more than 600 districts are
offering
some form of in-person learning
president biden says he wants to quickly
reopen schools calling for billions of
dollars in testing ventilation and staff
but yesterday he appeared to back the
teachers union saying schools must be
safe and secure
before students can return tony all
right meg thank you very much she really
puts her finger on an important debate
here
definitely kids do better in school
however you can understand the hesitancy
from teachers
i got a teacher at home in my house and
i know that would be your wife that
would be my wife and they
they want it to be safe and in some
cases the protocols just are not as
strict as they would like
it's a real dilemma they want to be back
in school too
yeah but they just everybody wants to be
back in school and it's not asking too
much to be safe while you're doing it
i get it and teachers need to be in that
first year of people getting the
vaccination in whatever state they're in
i know at least here in new york most of
them are having a very hard time getting
that
shot well there's a shortage it's an
issue all right meg thank you again